In the last quiz we determined an interval estimate that you're likely to make
with either major. So, in the case of nursing majors, between 50,000 and 60,000
and in the case of geography majors, between 40,000 and 55,000. But ideally, we
want one number that describes the entire data set, this allows us to quickly
summarize all of our data. Here's an analogy. Let's say you're describing
someone to a friend, there are a few words that you could use to describe that
someone like, tall, dark and handsome. Sometimes, 3 words will be accurate
descriptions, but let's say you can only choose one, cus you want to quickly
describe this person. Which word would you choose? The same with data, and just
like there are multiple words that could describe a single person, there may be
multiple numbers used to describe the whole data set.